Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Jago Di Piro
Fue el imperio de tierras continuas
más extenso de la historia:
desde Corea a Ucrania,
y desde Siberia al sur de China.
Y fue forjado en llanuras abiertas.
En el siglo XII d. C., antes de
la formación del Imperio mongol,
la estepa de Asia oriental
albergaba varios grupos dispersos
de nómades pastorales, mongoles
y turcos, liderados por un kan.
La gente criaba ganado,
como ovejas, yaks y camellos.
Vivían en tiendas de fieltro
y se desplazaban de un campamento
a otro entre el verano y el invierno.
Las mujeres nómades
tenían mucha autoridad:
se encargaban de estas migraciones,
del rebaño y del comercio.
Por otro lado, los hombres
se hacían cargo de las guerras.
Estos grupos nómades
a menudo luchaban entre sí.
Eso cambiaría con Temuyín, nacido
en una familia mongola aristocrática.
A pesar de perder a su padre
de muy joven y crecer en la pobreza,
ascendió rápidamente
forjando alianzas con otros líderes.
A diferencia de los demás kans, Temuyín
ascendía a los soldados según su mérito
y distribuía el botín
de forma equitativa entre ellos.
Su estrategia más exitosa
fue distribuir a los nómades conquistados
entre sus propias filas, para que así
no pudieran aliarse en su contra.
Estas innovaciones lo hicieron implacable
y, para el año 1206, ya había unido
a la gente de las tiendas de fieltro
y se había convertido en Gengis Kan.
Los mongoles eran chamanes:
creían que los espíritus de
la naturaleza y de sus antepasados
habitaban el mundo a su alrededor.
El más importante
era el dios del cielo, Tenggeri.
Gengis Kan creía que era voluntad
de Tenggeri que él conquistara
el mundo entero en su nombre.
Tras haber unido a los nómades
de la planicie mongola,
esta meta parecía estar a su alcance.
Quien se resistiera a los mongoles,
se resistía a la voluntad de Tenggeri.
Y por esta desobediencia, debía morir.
Liderados por Gengis Kan,
los mongoles subyugaron
primero el norte de China
y las tierras islámicas del este.
Tras su muerte en 1227,
el mandato divino pasó
a sus descendientes, o "linaje dorado".
En la década de 1230,
los hijos e hijas de Gengis Kan
conquistaron a los turcos de Asia central
y a los príncipes rusos.
Luego, destruyeron
dos ejércitos europeos en 1241.
En la década de 1250,
los mongoles se apoderaron de
territorios islámicos, Bagdad inclusive.
En Oriente, llegaron
hasta el sur de China en 1279.
La vida en el Imperio mongol no era
solamente guerras, saqueos y destrucción.
Después de conquistar territorios,
los mongoles no interferían
en las políticas internas,
y designaban para ellos
gobernadores locales.
También permitían todas las religiones,
siempre que sus líderes rezaran por ellos.
A pesar de que capturaban artesanos,
estudiosos e ingenieros con frecuencia,
reconocían su trabajo,
por lo cual los reubicaron por toda Asia
para que continuaran con su labor.
El producto más valioso del Imperio
era el brocado de oro,
creado a partir de la seda
de China, el oro del Tíbet
y los tejedores de Bagdad.
La vestimenta de los gobernantes
se hacía con brocado de oro,
también la de sus caballos
y la tela de sus tiendas.
Los mongoles otorgaban gran valor
a los técnicos en pólvora de China.
Con la mayor parte de Eurasia
unificada bajo un mismo gobernante,
el comerció creció
a lo largo de la ruta de la seda,
sustentado por un gran sistema
de mensajeros a caballo
y puntos de relevo.
El comercio marítimo también creció,
especialmente el de
la porcelana azul y blanca,
que combinaba la alfarería blanca
de la China mongola
con la tintura azul de Irán mongol.
Pero esto no podía durar.
El trono del gran kan no pasó
automáticamente a su hijo mayor,
sino que dio lugar a una competencia
entre hermanos, tíos y primos,
en la que las viudas
eran regentes de sus hijos.
Para la década de 1260,
los nietos de Gengis Kan
se encontraban en una completa
guerra civil por la herencia,
y dividieron el reino
en cuatro imperios individuales.
En China se recuerda
la dinastía Yuan de Kublai Kan
como la edad dorada
de la ciencia y la cultura.
En Irán, el Ilkanato
inauguró el desarrollo
de una nueva arquitectura monumental
y de la pintura persa en miniatura.
En Asia central, el Kanato de Chagatai
produjo líderes como Tamerlán
y su descendiente Babur, quienes
fundaron el Imperio mogol en la India.
Y en Europa oriental,
la Horda de oro reinó por años,
hasta que la compañía comercial Moscovita
se convirtió en un poder mundial.
Aunque su imperio
solamente duró unos años,
los mongoles dejaron un legado
de dominación mundial sin igual
que perdura hasta la fecha.